[Musik]
switler hat Blumen dabei wie immer wenn
sie ans Grab ihres Mannes geht es ist
gut zu erkennen an der ukrainischen
Flagge sie weht über jedem
soldatengrab bogdan ist in der Nähe von
bachmut gestorben drei Tage nach seiner
Beerdigung hat stlana erfahren dass sie
schwanger
ist es war schwer diese Tage
durchzustehen das waren die
schwierigsten überhaup
aber als ich erfahren habe dass ich
schwanger bin hat sich vieles
verändert sie und ihr Ehemann hatten
sich so sehr Kinder gewünscht jetzt ist
sie schwanger mit
Zwillingen es ist ein Glück zu wissen
dass er Kinder bekommen wird dass ich
sie zur Welt bringe ich fühle sie schon
und werde sie bald in meine Arme
schließen das ist große Liebe einfach
eine große Liebe
alle Z Wochen gehtlana zur
Vorsorgeuntersuchung sie ist 47 sie
konnte und wollte nicht länger warten
mit dem Kinderkriegen ihr Mann und sie
hatten sich deshalb für eine künstliche
Befruchtung
[Musik]
entschieden was für ein Glück das kann
man einfach nicht erklären sie sind das
Herz meines Mannes und seine
se ich die ärtin in Ihrer Klinik gibt es
viele Patientinnen wietlana der Krieg
bestimmt auf einmal die
Familienplanung wir werden kein anderes
Leben haben wir müssen dieses hier leben
und wir müssen dieses Leben planen
unsere Familiengenerationen
fortsetzen klar das ist nicht einfach
aber uns bleibt nichts anderes
übrig
dersturm der privaten Klinik in leevv
behandeln sie seit Kriegsbeginn 320
soldatenpaare kostenlos manche lassen
Sperma einfrieren manche entscheiden
sich gleich zur künstlichen
Befruchtung neues Leben erschaffen nach
welchen Regeln darf auch das Sperma von
Verstorbenen genutzt werden es ist eine
Frage die die ganze ukrainische
Gesellschaft
betrifft wir haben kein Recht dieses
Sperma zu nutzen und auch die Frau kann
es nicht einfach
nutzen vielleicht wird es in der Zukunft
ein Gesetz geben wir hoffen darauf dass
Frauen ihre Frauen dann dieses Sperma
nutzen können um schwanger zu
werden halinas Mann lebt noch auch er
ist Soldat auch ihre Tochter kam durch
künstliche Befruchtung zur Welt paina
ist Wochen alt ein
kriegsbaby ihr Mann und sie er
haben auch über sein möglichen Tod
gesprochen darüber haben wir gesprochen
obwohl wir natürlich hoffen dass er nach
Hause
zurückkommt es ist schrecklich darüber
zu sprechen aber man kann schon sagen
mein Mann wollte etwas
hinterlassen wie groß ist deine Angst
dass Polina eines Tages ohne ihren Vater
aufwachsen
muss es gibt dort sehr oft Explosionen
die Situation ändert sich dauernd zu
jeder Zeit kann etwas
passieren mehr will sie nicht sagen
Paulina wird wach deshalb will Halina
ihren man mititro an der Front erreichen
irgendwo im Osten das wichtigste ihm
Polina zeigen mit der er bis jetzt nur
fünf kurze Tage verbringen
konnte das ist so wichtig es ist gut zu
sehen wie meine Tochter groß wird wenn
auch nur auf distan
aber es ist wichtig zu sehen wie sie
aufwächst und wie schwer ist es so weit
weg von ihr zu sein und von
Halina wie soll ich das sagen es ist mit
Worten nicht zu beschreiben wie schwer
das ist das kann man nicht ausdrücken
aber so ist es
eben in der Ukraine gibt es Pläne dass
auch staatliche Kliniken Samenspenden
von Soldaten künstliche Befruchtungen
kostenlos anbieten um dem russischen
Vernichtungskrieg etwas entgegenzusetzen
Fortpflanzung als patriotischer Akt die
Helden Leben weiter so sieht das auch
der Arzt der stlana und ihren Mann
behandelt
hat ich erinnere mich wie ihr Mann zu
mir gesagt hat Stefan volodimirowitsch
ich will um jeden Preis dass sie
schwanger wird ich will dass nach mir
Kinder bleiben und da sitzt dieser Junge
vor mir und er lässt seinen Kopf hängen
und ihm laufen einfach nur die
Tränen welchen Preis zahlen die Väter
Mütter zahlt das ganze Land am Grab von
stlanas Mann treffen wir auch seine
Eltern ob ihn der Gedanke tröstet
Enkelkinder von boogdan zu bekommen will
ich von seinem Vater Wissen Trost ja
aber er hofft auf so viel
mehr die Hauptsache ist dass es Frieden
gibt ich denke dann kommt alles in
Ordnung in unserem Land Hauptsache
Frieden
Frieden der noch lange nicht in Sicht
ist und für den stlanas Mann sein Leben
gelassen
[Musik]
hat auch sie hat ganz klare
Vorstellungen von ihrer
Zukunft natürlich wünsche ich mir dass
mein Mann hier neben mir wäre und nicht
dass ich an seinem Grab stehe ich stelle
mich vor wie unsere Kinder an sein Grab
kommen und wie stolz sie auf ihn sein
werden dass er ein Held ist dass er
nicht nur mich verteidigt hat seine Frau
seine Eltern sondern die ganze
Ukraine ihren Kindern will sie von ihrem
Vater
erzählen dass er so auf sie gewartet
hat dass er sie so sehr
wollte